good morning we've not seen very much of
each other recently sorry about that
as I explained there are several very
good reasons I'm actually just walking
to work at the moment it's just gone
8:30 and I have some time so I thought
I'd explained myself time is thisis
pages so I've got to make the most of it
at the moment yeah so um I've been a bit
busy recently mmm
let's think what why have I not been
making videos firstly I had a week in
Walter but I went on tour the University
of Exeter Chapel Choir more about that
in a bit but that was a week where I was
away from my computer I think got back
as you saw in the last video I then
moved house the house light is left
which was a you know kind of stressful
experience and then immediately after
moving house I went to University of
Reading and I gave a talk
it is a couple of experiments stayed
there for several days and then got back
then had another week where I sung with
University of Exeter quite again but
this time for all the university
graduations as we sang for 18 ceremonies
it's very very loudly which included
going down to Cornwall to the second
campus that's another week where I
didn't really get a chance to do much in
between all of this I'm also going to
change hands because oh and that's in
between all of this I'm also writing my
thesis
like half the background chapter of my
thesis no not back on the theory chapter
Oh bad idea bad idea bad idea bad idea
I've also been making videos for the
university I've been making a day in the
life video for them so if you're
interested in it in the day in the life
of PhD student when that comes out I'll
let you know on my or my Twitter and
such that's actually kind of two days in
the life actually that's me and another
PhD student in archaeology called Emily
who happens work in the same building as
me but very different days so that's
coming out I'm also doing some videos
for local choir I'm oh videos to least
to us rather people that can't remember
off my head and then I have a bunch of
videos to you so the situation is I
haven't been making videos because well
actually have been making videos but
therefore things that either not for
this channel or there are four things
are going to come out way in the future
we're in the future so what's gonna be
coming out soon on this channel it's
probably the more pertinent question
that is one we went to Malta I blogged
exactly the same way that we did Germany
year before so several vlogs are gonna
be coming out other and I'm really
excited for it so gonna be really good
after those I've also shot a video
recently about my favorite films and
talking about those that's in the can
I've also got several videos on the
University of Reading where we recorded
some experiments that we recorded my
hair looking really terrible sorry I
couldn't find my hair gel this morning
we recorded a balloon launch which
logical balloon launch we did and and
some experiments in the fluid dynamics
lab that they have there which I think
really interesting if I added them right
there speaking of which actually that's
been the other problem is that I've been
getting used to editing with new
software so I have until now I've been
using bits of software called Sony Vegas
which i think is still fantastic what
I've done recently is upgrade and I've
got the Adobe Creative Cloud which means
I get things like Photoshop Lightroom
and more relevantly after-effects and
Prem
so more powerful editing software I've
been learning to use which is push back
my editing stuff even further but
hopefully that means the videos I finish
will be really really good looking which
is thanks to change for something on
this channel as well as those because of
moved house I might be doing a house
tour possibly and I'll actually hand
over to my housemate and I in the future
to talk about something else this is Dan
move that Kota this product placement
that way we don't get that guitar use I
use paint no this is Dan what's our new
channel called a new channel is to
rather choice adjectives which I think
aptly describes what the channels
content will be spongy and electric
there's a story behind its name we're
not going to tell you that could be we
could get the man on himself an origin
story origin story ok so that's that's a
video what what kind of videos we'll be
making yeah we kind of haven't decided
to Alateen on content yeah that's
exactly that we're doing something
possibly tonight we are and then it will
be a case of just kind of whipping out a
camera every now and then if something
vaguely humorous is going on yeah
speaking of vaguely humorous that's live
she's gonna be joining us on some of
these videos joy is it I think that was
a happy Mon yeah oh no that kind of can
we exceed it just for a moment move into
live does this often look at live space
nothing [ __ ] let's just go committed
and then what we should do is do bus
view cruise I will ask questions but not
tell you what the quiz is and then we
guess the quiz no no
well then I'll tell you what it is at
the heavens Percy oh and there's
possibly a music video coming up in this
channel featuring me singing because the
University of Exeter chapter 4 just
launched its first CD we might be doing
a music video on my channel we filmed it
we've edited it I just don't know when
that's coming out but baby oh that's
gonna be embarrassing so that's where we
are at the moment if things aren't
coming out as fast as you'd like bear in
mind that I am a real person and not
just a faithful on YouTube I actually
have other responsibilities like you
know trying to complete my mark my PhD
thesis which is definitely proving a
little bit tough at the moment that
things are coming just like I asked you
to be patient I actually again like I
said in the last video coming though I
really want to thank you for the
interactions that we got out of the
pouch of a video that was another time
sink because I promised I'd reply to
every single comment that guy was
definite just looking at you I promised
that I'd reply to every single comment
and I did a little bit unwieldy
considering the sheer number of comments
but it was fascinating like talking to
each of you and my girlfriend said it
might seem a little bit disingenuous but
I I genuinely was really interested to
like Ashley getting into a conversation
with some of you to get book
recommendations to talk about sort of in
some cases why you were doing some
things you were doing and if you were
doing exams were doing honestly it was
super super interesting to me so thank
you so much for being such an awesome
community of people I feel bad when I
don't get videos out regularly because I
felt like I'm letting you down I know
that's a stupid thing to say but I'm a
stupid person so I think stupid things
so
yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry to myself
feeling like I'm letting you down and
I'm hopefully the next videos that we
carry on this channel will be oh I don't
know actually
I can't believe a which one do you want
to see first
maybe I'll do those person okay right
come on campus now isn't it gorgeous I
seating and I sawed my hand oh and I
haven't forgotten about PhD watch or
have the help of the hook club books
I've owned nearly finished with spqr and
PhD which I got some great ideas I just
need is a stupid idea bells a surfboard
that's gonna take a little bit of time
to do having forgotten just in it